believe it or not earning a 0% rating on
Rotten Tomatoes is quite an achievement
reviewing a film is subjective of course
so critics pretty much always have
opposing arguments on the quality of a
movie but once in a while a movie comes
along that brings even the most stubborn
critics together to unanimously agree
the film is not worth your time here are
some of the unlucky films that managed
to pull off a 0% rating jaws the revenge
even if you haven't seen the fourth jaws
movie you may have read or heard Michael
Caine's famous quote on his involvement
with the ill-fated picture according to
the Telegraph he admitted I have never
seen it but by all accounts it was
terrible however I have seen the house
that it built and it is terrific 1987's
jaws the revenge single-handedly ended
the killer shark franchise by being
incompetent on every level developed
from conception to completion in less
than a year the movie was rushed and
careless with director Joseph Sargent
telling Starlog magazine at the time
this is probably the quickest gestation
of any project I think in film history
how do we get involve in something that
idiotic the lack of filmmaking expertise
on display along with an utterly
nonsensical premise makes for a viewing
experience that unfortunately isn't
worth your time and the critics all
agreed
Goti within days of its limited
theatrical release in 2018 this John
Travolta starring John Gotti biopic was
being confidently hailed as the worst
mob movie of all time it's hard to be
100% certain if that's true but it's
also hard to see how things could get
much worse Gotti's greatest sin is that
it's incredibly boring bizarrely edited
and difficult to follow the movie is
essentially a long collection of
technically uninteresting scenes
stitched together into something that
only sometimes looks like a film it's
confusing how they even got a movie star
in the lead role in an effort to combat
it's zero percent rating producers of
the film rolled out an ad campaign
claiming that it's not a movie for
critics but rather something general
audiences would enjoy I don't
like so dark crimes Jim Carrey became
widely known in the 80s and 90s for his
committed slapstick comedy performances
but he later surprised viewers with
impressive turns playing against type
and more serious films like man on the
moon and Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind with all that dramatic
talent it's unfortunate that 2018 s dark
crimes was such a fail focusing on a
detective who discovers startling
similarities between a cold case murder
and the plot of a recent novel dark
crimes has an interesting enough concept
to root for the movie from the start but
it never ever meets you they're
uncomfortable and unengaging dark crimes
earns its zero percent rating not
through apathy or blandness instead it
actively repulses digging its way down
to the bottom of the barrel one scene of
intense violence at a time look who's
talking now capping off the look who's
talking trilogy 1993's look who's
talking now takes the first two movies
conceit of tough talking babies and
broadens it with the introduction of a
team of talking dogs the insane
execution is the main problem here with
the seemingly family-friendly concept
perverted by enough bad language in the
window and adult humour to shut out the
age group that you'd think would be the
movies entire audience as a sequel
look who's talking now is one of the
all-time classic examples of the concept
of diminishing returns the unexpected
franchise had already given audiences a
retread with look who's talking to
making the completely unnecessary third
outing feel all the more puzzling the
ridiculous six Adam Sandler's early
successes have helped to sustain an
entire careers worth of unholy crapola
but 2015's the ridiculous six is his
rock bottom one of the few films that
truly deserves distinction among the
worst movies of all time in Sandler's
early movies the lowbrow quality of his
humor was still stupid but it felt like
you were in on a joke with the
ridiculous six it feels like you are the
joke it's like the
Derr took a dare to make the most
offensive least capable movie that
people would still watch the film also
comes across as mean-spirited steeped so
heavily in harmful Native American
stereotypes that several actors
reportedly left the set in protest max
steel superhero movies have spent the
last decade cleaning up at the box
office but that doesn't mean the genre
is a safe bet based on a toy line from
Mattel 2016 max steel is a false start
of an effort to bring a new franchise to
life it focuses on a young man named Max
and a robotic life-form from outer space
named steel the latter of which is a
joke cracking snark machine capable of
enveloping itself entirely around max
like a suit of armor the result is a
movie that tries to combine the best
elements of Iron Man and transformers
failing to accomplish either by
ultimately being too bland everything in
the movie is something you've seen
before and unfortunately all this
unforgivably boring film does is remind
you of other films that did it all
better
[Music]